bring in a Clay Matthews Packers
linebacker clay good morning thanks for
joining us absolutely my pleasure
all right runners walk us through what
it's like to get ready for a Thursday
night football as opposed to a Sunday
game I hardly agree with what drew had
to say I find it very difficult to get
ready for a Thursday night game
especially when you're coming off you
know Sunday game and I've had games
where we played in the the 325 time slot
so that's even less time to get ready
but I don't even start feeling good
until Thursday of the following week so
you know that morning I might be coming
around and then that night I'm expected
to go out there and you know obviously
perform at a high level so I think
there's a direct correlation despite
what you know was being said from the
league as far as injuries and statistics
and it's difficult you saw that last
night with you know sometimes a level of
play and at the same time with you know
injuries being had so it's you know it's
difficult but you know as long as the as
long as we're you know the league's
making money off it and you know people
are continuing to watch I don't see that
changing a foreseeable future but if it
was a players vote get rid of it or keep
it what do you think the numbers would
be and it didn't affect anything else
didn't affect revenue or because I you
know that's what that's what drives this
thing but I think if you just ask
players and it didn't affect anything I
think they'd get rid of those Thursday
games but don't you guys get is it work
out to a hundred thousand for each
player because the Thursday Night
Football is that number correct what
number would that be I'm not sure I'm
not I I think that it's like five
hundred million dollar
I think divvying it up it equals to 100
I don't know if it shows up in your
paycheck or not I don't know how that
works with the extra game with Thursday
night but I think Ross Tucker a former
NFL player said it worked out to over
$100,000 per player whether you see that
or not well I just I think you know the
fact that fans are still going to tune
in to watch these games even if it's you
know they're blowouts or you know
they're not as competitive as they were
last night even though that one came
down to the wire you know I think fans
are gonna watch because we've got a
great fan base and you know they want to
watch football but at the same time
sometimes you have to think about the
health of the players and I think
sometimes that's
overlooked all right let me talk about
the Packers here Aaron Rodgers back in
practice and that means what well I just
think it's the next step on him you know
hopefully coming back next week he's
looked great through his rehab process I
got to you know see him throwing the
ball several weeks ago and obviously
showcased a little bit before that
Sunday night game and now being able to
practice against us and in in practice
and where in the past I think it's just
the next step for you know hopefully his
return I'm not sure obviously I don't
have final say on if he's coming back or
not but if we can go ahead and get this
win this weekend and you know our
playoff hopes are still alive with those
last three games you know in front of us
especially with Aaron coming back
anything's possible so hopefully that's
just good news all around
would you have shaved your head if it
meant that Rodgers would have been able
to continue to play I like I love this
hair I mean it's priority okay all right
I understand that you and you have your
priorities set properly it's it's more
about your hair than the Packers and
Aaron Rodgers coming back I don't blame
you I'd probably feel the same way a
little bit okay we were also curious
your relationship with Rodgers and now
if I look at the commercials are the
commercials how close are they to your
actual friendship with there I would say
they're very close yeah you know I think
it's actually those are candid moments
in our lives where they just took
cameras along so what you see it wasn't
even scripted no but you know what's
funny is they actually you know these
corporate bigwigs hand us the script and
you know they got us you know using
these key words like bro and dude and
then Aaron and I look at the script and
we just you know like to have some fun
with it and you know kind of make it our
own so I think that's what makes them
authentic and what you know what I think
makes some good commercials the fact
that we lost antic and that's truly how
we interact with one another no you guys
sell it and it looks like that would be
but but you're not in the let's see I'm
trying to think if you're you're like
Jerry Lewis to his Dean Martin though
yeah but you know I I would I'm gonna
ask you a question when you watch these
clips and everyone knows Aaron is you
know the face of State Farm do you go oh
that's Aaron Rodgers commercial I think
I'm dominating these commercials oh as
long as Aaron's employed I'm employed
and that's that's good business but I
think this is why you're such a good
friend and teammate is you know it's
yours but you let Aaron think it's his
100% you know I need to build a
confidence in him let him spread his
wings because I've been in a major
motion picture before that's now coming
out with a third sequel but with him not
so much he's just stuck to commercials
and you and I can relate on us because
we're huge stars and have been in a
number of movies yeah I just don't know
if he has it quite yet he's he's on his
way though but just not where we are yet
now he's kind of shallow I mean he
insecure and he needs something right
now
in his life so I understand that I
understand that but that's that's me
that makes you you know and that's what
makes me special yes it does
could you see yourself as an action hero
when you're all done with football I
don't know you know I envision myself as
the next Howie Long you know the way he
was in Broken Arrow just kind of that
badass I think is what I would like to
be just because you know everyone knew
who he was but he was the big you know
muscled meathead bad guy who was you
know getting after Slater on that train
and I just I really could see myself
doing that Broken Arrow - yes yes
because there are a lot of questions
left unanswered in Broken Arrow and
Broken Arrow - will answer all of those
nuclear fallout you're right I like that
we're talking to a Clay Matthews the
Packers linebacker best team you face
this year was who we went down to
Atlanta and we - we you know we kind of
played the same team we had saw last
year in an NFC Championship game nothing
seemed to go our way and they seemed to
be on fire especially with them opening
up their new stadium that was a
difficult game for us but we bounced
back you know
nicely also I was wondering about your
dad your dad spent how many years with
the Browns 16 years with the Browns what
do you remember about that if anything
you know I was too young to really know
much of his playing time in Cleveland it
was more so his last three years in
Atlanta that I kind of remember you know
after his wins going on the field
running around 1:00 in the locker room
and stealing guys like Craig Hayward's
cleats and Jamaal Anderson weed my mom
said we walk out with mouthpieces and it
ain't just the Matthews boys were
stealing everything for the locker room
so well just on my fondest memories but
to bring it full circle though you know
going back to Cleveland it's special for
me just because I know you know what my
dad poured into that city and the
success they had there and you know some
of the some of the losses in which they
had to drive the fumble and you know the
cardiac kids so for me going back and
it's been a while the last time I was
back was 2009
I played there as a rookie so it's
always special when I'm able to get back
with your dad went through some
heartache man he did does he talk about
it I'm not really unless you know unless
he's provoked unless I asked him about
it why no I mean for the most part I
think the driving the fumble are two
games two plays that you know people
just seem to want to forget in Cleveland
history yeah he must hate Elway well
you've got a good trading card with him
sack in Delaware so I think he took it
out on him once or twice but yeah I mean
they you know they got after him and
don't you know I keep saying this said
this a dangerous game for you guys with
Cleveland and in people people say oh
now it's a Cleveland Browns are not any
good you know you've got Carolina the
following week and everybody's gonna be
talking about Aaron Rodgers man this is
a dicey game for some reason in my
opinion there with Cleveland well I
could see where the media you know
you're I mean you're right obviously a
lots being made you know I've been asked
for the past several weeks about you
know getting Aaron back and you know we
got to focus on the game in front of us
but you're right especially with
Cleveland who you know I don't want a
game and you know you could see a team
taking it for granted but I can assure
you this week we are
definitely not taking it for granted
you'd be foolish to just look at their
record and think that you know you're
gonna come in here for an easy win and
then focus on the last three games back
with Aaron but you know they do a number
of good things and they've been
competitive in a number of games and
they've got some young talent so you
know by no means do we think you know
this game is gonna be one-sided so it'll
be competitive and you know hopefully we
come out with a victory if you guys
don't make the playoffs and you aren't
busy for the postseason maybe you could
join NBC on their Super Bowl coverage
yeah well let's talk about this in like
five four or five weeks or something
like this all right okay just put it out
there just you know like I take it like
three or four games at a time you're
gonna take it one game at a time so like
just I'm getting to the regular season
already but all right yeah we can we can
revisit this if you want to not you know
I'll just get JJ Watt or somebody else
to do it right there so very good stuff
hey thanks for joining us have fun
against Cleveland and always great to
talk to you appreciate it take care now
that's Clay Matthews for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app